- This super-serious journalism
that everyone wants to know about.
- [Katy] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- This is like, really important topic.
- Yeah!
So our question we're
asking everybody today is:
what is the best song to have sex to?
- Oh, um, overall, I mean,
- Overall, yeah.
- It's a little Marvin
Gaye, maybe, but um,
I kind of love, maybe I
love a little Jeff Buckley,
but right now I love
"Often" by the Weekend.
- Just, just because of the word often?
- No, I mean I just think it's sexy.
I mean he's probably the
most sexual deliverer
of beautiful lyrics right
now, and I appreciate that.
- Yeah, well hey, thanks for
stopping by, I appreciate it.
- Or the Macarena!
- Like I didn't talk to anyone
else, but I love BuzzFeed.
- Thanks!
- Yeah because it's like, um, they have
all kinds of different posts of like,
Eat Your Way Around America Via Burritos,
- Yeah!
- or like The Weirdest Cats in the World.